desde el otro lado del mundo durante una
visita a la polinesia francesa
emmanuelle macrón tenía un mensaje para
sus críticos en casa arremetió contra
quienes dicen que el pase sanitario que
requiere prueba de vacunación o examen
negativo de ccoo y 19 para acceder a
distintos lugares atenta contra las
libertades civiles
gibert en la libertad no existe sin
responsabilidad la libertad en la que no
le debo nada a nadie no existe es
ficción es una mentira que la gente se
dice a sí misma mi libertad solo termina
donde la libertad del otro empieza pero
sobre todas las cosas todo se basa en un
sentido de reciprocidad del hip hop un
plan gubernamental para alentar a los
ciudadanos franceses a que se vacunen
ahora es ley
la votación está cerrada luz en la
madrugada del lunes la asamblea nacional
de francia aprobó el proyecto de ley con
una mayoría de 156 a favor frente a 60
en contra hubo 14 abstenciones después
de seis días de un intenso debate la
cámara baja y la cámara alta llegaron a
un acuerdo la asamblea estableció que el
proyecto de ley solo tendrá vigencia
hasta el 15 de noviembre en medio del
temor que la ley atenta contra las
libertades civiles y tomando en
consideración a los 160 mil
manifestantes que salieron a la calle a
protestar contra el pase sanitario el
fin de semana los legisladores
decidieron además que los trabajadores
de la salud no serán despedidos y se
rehúsan a vacunarse pero sus salarios
podrían ser suspendidos en cuanto al
pase sanitario la asamblea estableció
que será necesario para ingresar a
lugares en los que hayan más de 50
personas el ministro de salud de francia
tuiteó que fue una buena noche para la
democracia y elogió al senado por
encontrar un camino unido en la lucha
contra el virus después de su contienda
en la asamblea la ley ahora será
revisada por el consejo constitucional
un paso adicional sugerido por el primer
ministro para
para atender las preocupaciones de los
ciudadanos respecto a su libertad